colombia vive este 21 de septiembre una
caravana social por la vida y por la paz
organizada por el comité nacional de
paro que está formado por sindicatos y
también por movimientos sociales aquí en
la céntrica plaza bolívar de la capital
colombiana de bogotá era el lugar donde
tenían que construir 13 marchas que
salían desde distintos puntos de la
ciudad
sin embargo cuando había concentradas
apenas unos pocos miles de personas ha
empezado los enfrentamientos entre la
policía y los manifestantes cuando un
pequeño grupo ha lanzado piedras a la
policía también había otro grupo que ha
hecho una cadena humana para defender a
la policía de esas de esos lanzamientos
de piedras poco después en los aldeanos
de la plaza bolívar se han producido la
disipación de una de las marchas que
llegaba del sur cuando la policía tirado
también gases lacrimógenos y bombas
aturdidoras que los manifestantes han
respondido con piedras esta convocatoria
el 21 de septiembre es en memoria de los
13 fallecidos del 9 y el 10 de
septiembre que murieron a manos de la
policía por fuego real después de que se
quemasen también 70 estaciones de
policía además de estos hechos también
se están protestando por la gestión del
gobierno de la pandemia desde el punto
de vista económico y social unas
protestas que no sólo se han reducido a
vota sino
extendido en otras ciudades del país
como medellín cali barranquilla